this video is brought to you by squarespace from
websites and online stores to marketing tools and
analytics squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and run your
business check out squarespace through the link in
the description below more on them in just a bit
if you think of an authoritarian
despot you're probably picturing some
decisive charismatic and ruthless leaders someone
who addresses the masses in a commanding booming
voice basking in the glow of a cult of personality
today's protagonist doesn't fill that description
not at all he remained a background character
a fence sitter for much of his life and
even when he rose to power he never projected a
menacing aura in fact he wished to be remembered
as the smiling general but don't let an
unassuming smile fool you mr saharto was
a cunning and manipulative ruler capable of
swift violent action when times called for
it this is the story of how ceharto rose
to power in indonesia during one of the
worst massacres of the 20th century and how he
maintained power while bleeding the country dry
sahada was born on the 8th of june 1921 in
kamusu agyamuya near yogi yakata so sorry
about pronunciation this is in the island of
java modern day indonesia but at the time it
was part of the dutch east indies he was named
just sahato as is common for many indonesians
regarding his family well there's not much we can
say with certainty according to the man himself
his parents were poor peasants rumors speculated
that he was the legitimate son of a chinese
businessman while sources close to military
intelligence claimed that his parents
were of aristocratic stock more realistically his
father may have been a village irrigation official
so not a poor peasant but certainly not an
aristocrat either regardless of his origins
sardo's family could certainly not splash the
cash in fact he once had to drop out of school
because he couldn't afford the required uniform
the young sahato had more clothing malfunctions
after graduating high school he had secured
a job as a bank clerk but after his suit got
torn in a bicycle accident he had to quit the
job there was one employer which could provide
the right attire at any time though the military
as a means to elevate his social standing sahato
joined the dutch colonial forces when the imperial
japanese navy invaded indonesia in 1942 the young
soldier promptly switched uniforms he joined
a japanese-sponsored militia where he trained
as an officer sure the japanese were invaders
but they were not as hated as the retreating
dutch colonial overlords in fact when the japanese
surrendered in august 1945 zahaso joined the newly
formed indonesian army fighting for independence
against the returning dutch occupation forces
this new force was led by generals ahmed sakhano
and muhammad hatha inspired by nationalist and
anti-colonialist ideology the two officers
also relied on the support of communist
and islamic factions the fragile balance between
these three forces nationalism communism religion
would be a staple of indonesian
politics for many years to come
all right so let's get back to the fight for
independence dutch forces had landed in sumatra
and java making considerable territorial
gains the indonesian forces were armed with
equipment left over by the japanese but the
lack of heavy weaponry meant that they had
to resort to guerrilla tactics the uniformed
army also lacked trained officers which may
explain why sahato was promoted to the rank of
lieutenant colonel at the young age of just 24
and he was in for more promotions in 1948 sahara
was given command of a brigade stationed around
yogyakarta he had the chance to prove his
worth on the 19th of december when dutch
forces attacked by surprise well he couldn't
really prove much as his entire brigade
happened to be outside of the city the dutch
captured yogyakarta without firing a shot a
serious setback for the anti-colonial forces
in march of 1949 sahato led a counter-attack to
retake the lost positions this action was later
immortalized in the epic 979 film janukooning
but in reality there wasn't really much to be epic
about the attack was repulsed after six hours and
it didn't really do much damage to the enemy
nonetheless the struggle for freedom had
continued with more success elsewhere by 1949 the
anti-guerrilla campaign was proving too costly to
the dutch government moreover the international
community didn't support this colonial cause
devastated by the german occupation in world
war ii the netherlands badly needed financial
aid from the u.s which came with a condition leave
indonesia alone in december of 1949 the republic
of indonesia was granted independence with socano
as president and hatta as prime minister saharto
had received a further promotion to colonel over
the following years he remained in the background
as an unremarkable figure which nonetheless
rose steadily through the ranks in 1959 he
was appointed major general in command of the
central java military district this appointment
was short-lived though as his superiors removed
him on allegations of accepting bribes and yet he
managed to regain his position shortly afterwards
and continue on with his career by 1963 the
general had become head of the army strategic
command a rapid reaction force based in the
capital city of jakarta tasked with responding to
national emergencies it was a prestigious posting
but sahato could do a bit better and
he did two years later the ambitious
officer reported directly to general yani the
commander-in-chief of the army whenever daddy
was traveling ill or otherwise incapacitated
sahato would take his role in the interim it
all seemed set for sahato to take over during
an emergency one that would very soon come along
but before we get there let me give you some
background on how tensions were building in
the country in 1959 president secano implemented
an authoritarian system called guided democracy
which allowed him to exert large influence over
the parliament his agenda during guided democracy
was based on three points first a shift towards
socialist and populist reforms a continuation
of the anti-dutch revolution second a strong
anti-colonialist stance in foreign affairs matters
third economic self-reliance and nationalization
of foreign assets however poor implementation
of agricultural reforms and economic policies
resulted in low production levels compared with
inflation this in turn contributed to social
unrest and the growing popularity of the pki
the indonesian communist party by 1965 the
pki claimed to have 3.5 million members it
could also rely on 23.5 million members in
affiliated organizations trade unions and
youth movements for example this made the pki the
largest communist party outside of the ussr and
china while many officers supported the pki the
army saw its growing popularity with suspicion of
fearing a communist takeover of the country
they started to meet with religious leaders
forging a preemptive alliance amidst the backroom
maneuvering zahato sat firmly on the fence then in
the latter half of 1965 rumors reached socano's
inner circle that a group of leftist officers
were planning a coup in the early hours of october
the first 1965 things came to a head an armed
group called the 30th of a september movement
kidnapped six of the highest ranking generals
and one lieutenant the seven officers
were then executed and dumped into a well
in east jakarta this violent action caused
the death of an eighth innocent victim
the six-year-old daughter of general association
the movement's leader lieutenant colonel and tung
of the presidential guard ordered the seizure
of the state broadcasting service from there
the insurgents proclaimed a new revolutionary
government but who was behind this coup according
to professor john russa from the university
of british columbia some top leaders of the
pki had played a role in the plot but most party
cardras were unaware of the plans the pki's youth
organization had also been trained for military
action but were left on standby without orders and
they had no idea that they would go after the army
rusa also noted how two of the conspirators were
good friends of sahato one of them colonel latif
later declared in court that zahato was aware of
their plot to kill the officers all in all at
least part of the pki was behind the plot tarto
was aware of it but he did nothing to prevent it
it was only a few hours after the assassinations
that zahato finally decided to jump off his fence
and take advantage of his emergency powers just
before we get into the rest of today's video
a word from today's sponsor squarespace look
it's a new year so whatever that new thing you're
thinking about doing maybe it's a resolution of
some kind maybe you're resoluting is that a word
to start a new website well do it with squarespace
with squarespace the world is yours it's the
platform to use when you've got a new web project
you want to do if you want to get in and out quick
use one of their beautiful templates they're very
easy you pick one it's beautiful then your website
is almost good to go maybe you've got to change
the text and a few things around otherwise it
just looks like the template but it's very easy
or maybe more of a hands-on person like templates
are for me those look great but i've got design
skills well great news squarespace is heavily
customizable so you can make it look however you
want it to look and then there are no updates no
patches no technical nonsense to worry about and
once you've done setting up your website there's
tons of extra features so that it can thrive email
complaints patronage portals social integrations
member only areas analytics commercial options
24 7 customer support that's a lot of things in
fact seven things they're all in one easy place
called squarespace so when you're ready to get
started on the next project of yours big or small
if it involves a website do it with squarespace
go to squarespace.com for a free trial and when
you're ready to launch your new site go to
squarespace.com forward slash biographics
and you'll save 10 of your first purchase of a
website or a domain and back to today's video
one of the murdered officers was general yanni
with him gone zahato was formally in command
of the army he quickly stepped into the phrase
swiftly repressing the 30th of september movement
and controlling the narrative of the events he and
other top officers inflamed public opinion against
the pki squarely blaming the assassinations and
the attempted coup on the entire organization it
supporters and according to documents declassified
by the us government the cia supported zohato and
his propaganda efforts by supplying communications
equipment but despite the propaganda and pressure
from the generals socano refused to ban the pki
this was all the motivation that zahato needed
to initiate a violent purge against the party
his first action was to dispatch the rp kad the
paratrooper commando units to central java
and bali here communist party leaders party
members or just suspected sympathizers were
rounded up and slayed on mass the massacres
soon spread throughout the entire archipelago
often the killings were perpetrated directly by
the regular armed forces they were mostly busy
and purging those units who had sided with kpi
the presidential guard two divisions in central
java and much of the air force when it came to
civilians the military preferred to arm and
train militia units and allow the militias to
carry out the dirty work these militias
were recruited mainly amongst the ansar the
youth wing of the islamic national organization
llama or nu the enu was already anti-communist
but to further motivate them army officers
circulated the news that pkl activists held
hit lists of islamic leaders from the perspective
of the ansar it was a case of kill or be killed
the answer was not alone the army mobilized now
members of the catholic and nationalist parties
most of these militias operated in rural areas
an armed band would target a village suspected
of supporting the pki they would surround it seize
party members and sympathizers and detain them in
temporary detention centers where prisoners
were tortured and interrogated what happened
next is best described by a chilling declassified
cable sent by edwardi masters political affairs
councillor at the u.s embassy in jakarta on the
30th of november 965 he wrote repression of the
phi continued with the main problem that's of
what to feed and where to house the prisoners
many provinces appear to be successfully meeting
the problem by executing their pki prisoners or
killing them before they are captured prisoners
were marched into the forests for the final act
they were shot stabbed beaten to death and
their bodies dumped into mass graves in many
cases bodies were thrown into rivers or left to
rot in the streets to further terrorize local
populations militias took to mutilating corpses
and leaving their heads and genitals in full view
the purges continued into 1966 while
no documents have proven that zahato
directly ordered the killings he was at the
top of the chain of command and directed the
actions of the paratroopers and the training of
the militias professor russa guesses that zahato
must have at least approved of the massacres
according to professor brad simpson university
of connecticut the extermination of the pki
propelled his career even further socano
far from doing anything concrete to stop
the bloodshed confirmed sahato's status
as commander-in-chief and on the 11th of march
1966 the president signed the supersema decree
which bestowed sahato with full powers to
guarantee security calm and stability in the
country the general interpreted this decree to his
advantage arresting 15 ministers and dismissing
the rest of the cabinet by march 12th zahato was
the de facto head of the indonesian government
with cicada still in place as nominal president
in march 1967 the people's consultive assembly
appointed sahato acting president the consolation
of his power became complete exactly one year
later in march of 1968 the assembly elected
zahato was president with full powers for the
first of many five-year terms the low-profile
general until now a power in the shadows
had risen to full power sailing unscathed amidst
a tempest bloodshed he and a circle of officers
had instigated it's still difficult to estimate
the toll that this purge exacted on the indonesian
people due to a lack of reliable records estimates
of mass murders range from a hundred thousand to
two million victims historian robert krib
suggests that half a million dead could be
an accurate figure in addition to those slain
almost three-quarters of a million indonesians
were imprisoned with sentences ranging from one to
thirty years many high-ranking members of the pki
were sentenced to death while most members were
sentenced to hard labor members of the gewani the
movement of conscious indonesian women were also
subjected to sexual abuse and rape while in jail
in march 1966 sahato began implementing a series
of policies which he called oda bahru or new
order the first policy shift was to deeper to
size indonesian society sahato created a system
by which citizens were organized in hundreds
of functional groups one for peasants one for
civil servants one for business owners and so on
the tactic was designed to prevent the formation
of trade unions and to ensure capillary control
of the population these groups were coordinated
by the organization galongankaya or golkar for
short which became the predominant political party
sato also ensured that the military fulfilled
a dual function both as a defense organization
and as a political force becoming the actual
rulers of the country then sahato restored ties
with the west and put an end to a costly military
confrontation with malaysia initiated by socano
in january of 1963. finally sarato realized
that a stable rule required improving living
standards for indonesians to boost the economy
he did a u-turn on socano's policies no more
talk of self-reliance on nationalization the new
ruler welcomed with open arms foreign investments
especially in the oil sector and if ungrateful oil
workers dared to form unions and kick up a stink
no problem sarto's soldiers would intervene
to preserve a harmonious working environment
another pillar of sahato's stability was the
massive growth of the public sector by the
early 1970s about 1.5 million indonesians were
employed by the state the number tripled over
the next three decades civil servants not only
enjoyed a steady salary they were also provided
a chance to boost revenue with some bribery on the
side this system guaranteed zahadu and golkara a
steady base of voters at every election in the
late 1970s sahato also sought to build a more
benevolent image for himself to the outside world
who largely saw him as a despot he opened the
country to foreign investment and had to bow to
certain international pressure at least partially
i wanted him to dial down the authoritarianism
you know just a tad and he did this he released
tens of thousands of political prisoners but this
is not to say that the smiling general renounced
his old ways the army was always ready to react
with swift brutality against real or perceived
threats especially against those movements
who threatened the integrity of the nation
for example the local population in papua was kept
in a state of constant violent counter-insurgency
by the armed forces this happened all the
way from the late 60s to 1998. yet during
the late 1960s and early 1970s indonesia under
sahato's new order appeared like a success story
sato's rule was definitely authoritarian yet
he was clever enough to always operate within
constitutional boundaries the new president
had successfully restored order to the country
although we may argue that he and his faction
were largely responsible for the initial state
of disorder indonesia had also become a key
player in the game of chess that was the cold war
before socano could drift toward the communist
bloc zahato had yanked the country in the opposite
direction under his authority jakarta became one
of the founding members of the association of
southeast asian nations or asian the equivalent of
nato for the region but his greatest achievement
was to restore economic growth under the new
order every year the local economy grew 6.6
on average living standards improved in general
although the public sector the military and urban
elites benefited more than other classes this
growth was driven by foreign investments and
especially by the mass export of indonesia's vast
natural resources mainly oil and timber revenues
from these sales were reinvested by the government
into the expansion of urban and suburban areas
as well as literacy programs and family planning
initiatives but this expansion had a rotten core
sahato and his cabinet failed to reinvest into the
development of state infrastructure and into the
local manufacturing sector worse than that much
of the income from oil and timber disappeared into
the deep pockets of sahato his allies and his
six children an example of this mismanagement
is the state-owned oil company pertamina compared
to the malaysian equivalent patronus this company
had access to much larger oil reserves and yet it
consistently unperformed compared to its neighbor
in theory pertamina could have been a cash cow
in practice it was only milked by sahara's family
now cracks in the international facade began to
form in the mid-1970s most population was pretty
fed up with the corruption and collusion and
the nepotism that was rampant in sahato's circle
students were especially disillusioned
with the inflow of foreign investments and
how they were essentially just funneled straight
into sahato's wallet on january the 15th of 1974
japanese prime minister kakoe tanaka was
in jakarta for an official visit it was the
perfect occasion for thousands of students to
stage massive protests and thus embarrass the
authoritarian leader the protests degenerated into
12 hours of riots with fires blazing throughout
jakarta these became known as the malari rods
sato reacted with a signature mix of the carrot
and the stick first he had 12 newspapers
shut down and its journalists imprisoned
without a draw the remaining publications
began applying a form of self-censorship which
effectively curbed any dissenting voice but then
he complied with some of the protesters requests
the government enacted restrictive measures on
foreign investments favoring the development of
local businesses the next crisis took place in
november of 1975. the east now for the island
of timur until then a portuguese colony declared
independence the independent east timor was led by
the left-leaning party teflon and sahato could
not tolerate a communist threat on its borders
in december the army invaded annexing east
timor as the 27th province of indonesia the
international community protested the
invasion and the u.n did not recognize
the annexation but in practical terms joha's
troops were free to garrison the territory and
even freyja to carry out a brutal campaign of
repression which claimed up to 200 000 lives
international star sean again briefly in the
following decade in 1985 he traveled to rome
for an award ceremony at the headquarters for the
food and agricultural organization the fao he was
celebrated for having raised rice production in
indonesia the country was now self-sufficient
in that respect and didn't need to import rice
any longer but that was a temporary triumph sure
crops have been growing from 1977 to 1982 but they
started to decline soon afterward since then the
government had in fact encouraged the conversion
of rice paddies into suburban development projects
by the early 1990s indonesians were back to
importing large shipments of rice mismanagement
and corruption had created a bit of a paradoxical
situation indonesia had all the fertile land and
agricultural labor required to feed its growing
population in theory in practice arable land was
destined for other purposes and hundreds of
thousands of farmers were forced to migrate
seeking employment in neighboring countries the
regime had thus alienated any remnant of support
by the rural masses next in line were the backbone
of gold car supporters middle class civil servants
and small business owners until then the mirage
of continued growth had kept them at bay and
silenced any voice rising against the bad habit of
pocketing the kickbacks in 1997 however indonesia
became one of the main victims of currency crisis
which devastated the economies of southeast asia
the country faced every economist's worst
nightmare stagflation a lethal mix of recession
and soaring inflation zahato resisted demands for
structural reforms while living standards rapidly
collapsed nationwide a mass movement for reformacy
or institutional reform took to the streets
anti-government demonstrations broke out
in jakarta and other cities in may of
1998. confronted by the security forces protests
escalated into violent riots which claimed more
than a thousand victims by now the once smiling
general realized that he lacked the political and
military backing to intensify the crackdown on may
21 of 1998 zahato saw the writing on the wall and
thought it was best to resign his deputy baka
rodinius of habibi became indonesia's third
president sato left power with an apology
to the nation i'm sorry for my mistakes
well i mean thanks but maybe it's not enough in
fact the new cabinet demanded more than an apology
in 2000 the government filed embezzlement charges
against him sato was accused of misappropriating
the equivalent of more than 600 million us dollars
but the former despot was in ill health and the
charges were dropped in 2007 the un and the world
bank estimated the true extent of his pilfering
value was estimated between 15 and 35
billion american dollars in 2007 time
magazine picked up the story reporting that
sahara and his family had stolen 15 billion
the magazine was sued for defamation a court
case which zahato won in november of that year
in the meantime the indonesian government
tried again to sue him for embezzlement
and in december they announced an investigation
into six cases of human rights abuse one of
them was about the massacres of 1965-66 but
sato would never face trial on the 4th of
january 2008 the former general and president was
hospitalized due to complications of renal failure
among many other ailments his health quickly
worsened due to internal bleeding and sepsis
sarto was declared dead on the 27th of january
but then president yudhoyono asked indonesians
to respect one of their top countrymen just
two months earlier that top countryman had
laughed off his allegations it's all empty talk
let them accuse me the fact is i have never
committed corruption so i really hope you found
today's video interesting if you did please do
hit that thumbs up button below don't forget to
subscribe and as always thank you for watching